the post is directed by Steven Spielberg
and stars Meryl Streep Tom Hanks Bob
Odenkirk and my man Pat Healy so awesome
to see him in a Steven Spielberg movie
he's a really great guy I got to meet
him one time he was super awesome and I
know for a fact he was probably nerding
out every single time he was on set with
Spielberg and all those people so it was
so cool to see him in this film and this
film tells the true story of the
Pentagon Papers this is a big event that
happened in history right before
watergate broke it was a scandal that
involved the government's knowledge of
things that they weren't revealing to
the public and when the Washington Post
got the proof of these things Nixon
decided you know what the press is going
to be sued and we're going to shut down
all of these newspapers anybody who
talks about this anyone who reveals
classified information you're all
screwed and that's what I'm gonna do and
so the reporters are faced with a
dilemma do we publish this information
can we figure out what this information
is can we sift through it in enough time
to get the paper published tomorrow
morning or should we even do it at all
Spielberg fast-tracked this film into
production when he got a hold of the
script he had already completed filming
ready player one and that's in
post-production now and he went to shoot
this movie unplanned and pretty much
right out of left field because he was
so passionate about the source material
he felt the script was very relevant for
today's climate and it is today's world
has the Trump administration constantly
calling out the media and trying to
control it and figure out what
information the public is getting and
what information the public isn't
getting and we've seen a lot come out
about that in the news recently and the
post is a very relevant film for today's
climate and it's one of the things that
I think works the most about it in
future years perhaps in future decades
that will remain to see how well this
film holds up against films like all the
president's men which was actually about
Watergate and is an excellent film still
today the post does not feel like it
will age as well as that film and a lot
of that has to do with what Spielberg
chooses to focus on and what the script
chooses to focus on sometimes it tries
to communicate the difficulties of
running a paper and how hard it was back
then they show just how much physical
labor actually went into getting a
paper printed in time which I thought
was pretty interesting and definitely
something that made the film have a
realistic tone all that being said
sometimes the more dramatic elements of
this story that do we publish this what
are the ramifications of publishing this
will we end up in jail
sometimes those more riveting elements
are pushed to the background making the
first half of the film drag because it's
not until the last half that these
Pentagon Papers get in the hands of
these reporters and from that moment on
I thought the film drastically improved
and became very exciting it's that first
half that feels a little unfocused
because they're setting up real conflict
with Meryl Streep who is the owner of
the Washington Post she's thinking about
going public with the paper thus giving
up some authority that she already has
and there are men behind the scenes
trying to abuse their power against her
because they think they can and so that
is also very relevant for today but once
they get the papers in their hands the
film becomes that riveting journalism
drama that I wanted from the beginning
standouts here for myself for Bob
Odenkirk I think he deserves a Best
Supporting Actor nomination he was
terrific and Hank's his character
scruffy he's seasoned he's been around
for a long time he's seen everything
there is to see in this business and he
plays it beautifully as usual Streep is
good she is a little Oscar Beatty in
fact a lot of people are going to say
this movie is a little Oscar Beatty and
in many ways you can look at it like
that and there's sequences where it
feels like okay this is where Spielberg
is directing his big on inspiring moment
for this character and it just sort of
does feel like those Spielberg moments
were used to seeing like here comes that
scene where we slowly Dali in on someone
as they tell us a great speech about
their life and it's supposed to be
really inspiring and John Williams music
swells and in the past with great films
like bridge of spies which i think is
highly underrated that really works it's
because the characters were set up
better and in this film the characters
don't have the same type of meat on
their bones that if film like bridge of
spies had so the best things about the
post are that it's extremely timely and
very relevant to today's conversation
the performances across the board are
all uniformly
great the last half is extremely
riveting that first half though is a
little tough to get through because it
feels a little like where are we going
when are we going to get to what we know
is happening but I would recommend
seeing the post and I'm gonna give it a
B I was expecting it to be a little
better considering Spielberg
fast-tracked it into production and he
was so inspired by the script but this
is still a good movie and one filled
with great work and he should see it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]